हेलो एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी
गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। तो सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है? प्लीज चैट में बता
दीजिए।
ठीक है।
ओके सबको मेरी आवाज सुनाई दे रही है?
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। हेलो हेलो
वेरी गुड इवनिंग टू ऑल। ओके। तो प्रीवियस
क्लास में किसी को कोई डाउट है?
किसी को कोई भी डाउट है प्रीवियस क्लास
में जो हमने पढ़ी थी।
कोई भी डाउट हो आपको रिलेटेड टू द क्लास।
चलो मेरे को यह बताओ प्रैक्टिस किस
किस-किस ने की थी प्रीवियस क्लास वाले
पेलोड की।
उसी से पता चलेगा कि आपके डाउट है भी या
नहीं।
बताओ
कोई डाउट नहीं है?
इट्स ओके।
तो आज की जो क्लास स्टार्ट हो रही है
हमारी वो कंटिन्यू है। वेपनाइजिंग वीबीए
मैलोड। ठीक है? जो वीबीए का जो मैक
पेलोड्स है उसी के ऊपर कंटिन्यू है बट
प्रीवियस क्लास से थोड़ी सी एडवांस है
थोड़ी सी उससे एडवांस है और ये भी पूरी
प्रैक्टिकल क्लास है तो प्रीवियस क्लास
में हमने क्या जो भी स्क्रिप्ट लिखी थी
अगर आपने नोटिस की हो अगर आपको कोई भी
आईडिया हो कि हमने किस टाइप की स्क्रिप्ट
लिखी थी किस टाइप का मिलसियस पे लोड लिखा
था अगर आप लोगों ने प्रैक्टिस की होती या
आप लोग आप आप लोगों ने थोड़ा सा रिवीजन
किया होता या उसको दोबारा पढ़ा होता तो
आपके मन में एक सवाल आता कि सर यह
स्क्रिप्ट जो है आपने प्रोवाइड की या जो
आपने हमसे डेवलप करवाई क्या यह स्टिल्थी
स्क्रिप्ट है? क्या इसको डिटेक्ट किया जा
सकता है? नहीं किया जा सकता। लेकिन मैं
आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं।
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
ओके। तो आपको एक चीज बता देता हूं कि जो
स्क्रिप्ट हमने प्रीवियस क्लास में डिजाइन
की थी हमारे सिनेरियो पर स्क्रिप्ट जो
मिलिशियस पेलोड हमने
हमने डिजाइन किया था उसमें एक प्रॉब्लम
थी। प्रॉब्लम क्या थी कि उसको बहुत ही
आसानी से डिटेक्ट किया जा सकता था आपके
किसी भी सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन या
सिक्योरिटी टीम के द्वारा। ठीक है? अब जब
हम बात करें रेड टीम ऑपरेशन की अगर आपको
रेड टीम ऑपरेशन में सर्वाइव करना है तो
हमें ऐसे पेलोड्स बनाने पड़ेंगे या हमें
ऐसी मिलिश स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी होगी जो
सिक्योरिटी सॉल्यूशन जैसे आपके एंटीवाएस
आपके एडीएस या विंडोज डिफेंडर को बायपास
कर सके या उनकी नजर में कम आए। अब मैं
आपको 100% स्टिल्थ पेलोड लिखना नहीं
सिखाऊंगा बिकॉज़ दिस इज अ YouTube। YouTube
पे यह अलाउड नहीं है। ओके? बट आपको थोड़ा
सा मैं स्टिल ही पेलोड लिखना की प्रैक्टिस
डलवा दूंगा ताकि आप लोगों को आईडिया मिले
कि जो पेलोड मैं अभी बना रहा था क्या वो
मैं इसको और भी बेहतर बना सकता हूं या
नहीं बना सकता और अगर मुझे इस पेड को और
भी बेहतर बनाना है तो मुझे किन-किन बातों
की किन-किन नॉलेज की और क्या-क्या और
सीखने की जरूरत है वो सारी चीजें आपको
थोड़ा-थोड़ा हिंट मिल जाएगी, आईडिया मिल
जाएगा। ओके? तो आमतौर पर जब भी हम क्या
करते हैं Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की बात
कर रहे हैं खास करके कि जब भी हम Windows
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम में कोई भी हार्डवेयर या
सॉफ्टवेयर की इंफॉर्मेशन निकालना चाहते
हैं तो हम क्या करते हैं? हम या तो सीएमडी
का यूज़ करते हैं या हम wmआई.exc
जैसे एक्सटर्नल कमांड का यूज़ करते हैं।
जिसको हम wmआई भी बोलते हैं। wmआईसी जैसी
कमांड का भी हम यूज़ करते हैं। यह सबको पता
है। लेकिन यहां पर प्रॉब्लम है। प्रॉब्लम
यह है। कि जब भी आप कोई भी एक्सटर्नल
कमांड का यूज करते हैं अपने पेलोड में या
आप एक्सटर्नल कमांड्स को बैकग्राउंड में
रन करते हैं ड्यूरिंग योर पेलोड
एग्जीक्यूशन जैसे कि हम सीएमडी का
एग्जांपल ले लें या जो wmआई डॉट exc है
उसका एग्जांपल ले लें तो क्या होता है कि
जब भी आप बैकग्राउंड में एक्सटर्नल कमांड
को यूज़ करते हो तो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम पर एक
नई प्रोसेस क्रिएट होती है उसके अगेंस्ट
और जिसका रिकॉर्ड क्या होता
आपका [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] जो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है अगर वह किसी नेटवर्क
का हिस्सा है या किसी वो एक्टिव
डायरेक्टरी एनवायरमेंट में है चाहे या
नॉर्मल भी है तो उसका एक लॉग बन जाता है
आपके सिस्टम के अंदर। ठीक है? जैसे कि ये
हमारा एग्जांपल है। प्रीवियस क्लास में
हमने क्या देखा था कि हमने
एक मशियस
माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट किसके पास
भेजा? आपके टारगेट मशीन के पास। और सबको
पता होगा कि हमने टारगेट मशीन के पास एक
मिलिशियस माइक्रोसॉफ्ट वर्ड डॉक्यूमेंट
भेजा था। तो अब जब हमने वो डॉक्यूमेंट
भेजा और जैसे ही यूजर ने उस पर डबल क्लिक
किया स्टेप वन पे तो उसके अगेंस्ट एक आईडी
जनरेट हुई। उसके अगेंस्ट एक इवेंट जनरेट
हुआ सिस्टम में जिसकी इवेंट आईडी थी वन।
और इवेंट आईडी तब जनरेट होती है जब कोई
प्रोसेस क्रिएट होती है। यहां एक विंडो
सिक्योरिटी आईडी 4688।
अभी यह कोई सस्पिशियस नहीं था। यह कोई
सस्पिशियस चीज नहीं है क्योंकि किसी भी
एनवायरमेंट में विंड खासकर की चाहे आपका
कोई भी कंपनी हो कोई भी ऑर्गेनाइजेशन हो
MS Word MS एक्सेल्स आउटलुक जैसी चीजें
बहुत कॉमन है। तो इनकी प्रोसेस क्रिएट
क्रिएट होना बार-बार कोई सस्पिशियस नहीं
है। इस पे कोई ऐसा नहीं है कि हम उस पे
सस्िशियस
उस पे रेड फ्लैग रेज कर दे क्योंकि एक
नॉर्मल बात है। तो जब भी कोई प्रोसेस
क्रिएट होती है तो उसका क्या होता है? एक
सिस्ट एक इवेंट आईडी जनरेट हो जाती है।
जैसे कि इस केस में भी हुआ। कोई बात नहीं।
ये एक नॉर्मल इवेंट आईडी थी स्टेप वन पे।
उसके बाद यूजर ने क्या किया? जैसे ही
इनेबल कंटेंट किया तो हमारी स्क्रिप्ट
एग्जीक्यूट करती है। अभी जो यह आईडी जनरेट
हुई थी इसकी जो प्रोसेस होती है किसकी? MS
Word की जो MS Word है उसकी जो प्रोसेस
होती है ठीक है उसकी प्रोसेस का नाम है
winword.exc
उसकी प्रोसेस का नाम क्या है? विनव exc
ओके और जब स्टेप थ्री की बात आई जैसे ही
विनव exc एग्जीक्यूट हुआ एग्जीक्यूट होते
ही उसके बैकग्राउंड में एक मिलिश पे लोड
था किसका मैक का वीबीए में लिखा हुआ तो
उसने क्या किया हमें इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग करनी थी सिस्टम
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन नेटवर्क डिटेल इंस्टॉल्ड ये
ये सारी इनेशन चाहिए थी इस इंफॉर्मेशन के
लिए हमें किसकी रिक्वायरमेंट थी सीएमडी की
तो इसने क्या किया एक प्रोसेस क्रिएट की
किसकी सीएमडी की जिसके अगेंस्ट एक और
सिस्टम आईडी जनरेट हुई। एक इवेंट आईडी
जनरेट हुई वन। अब यह सस्िशियस है क्योंकि
सोच के देखो कि आपने MS Word ओपन किया कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं। अब MS Word किसको
ओपन कर रहा है? सीएमडी को। MS Word किसको
ओपन कर रहा है? आपके सीएमडी को। तो पहला
सस्िशियस इवेंट यहीं पर जनरेट हो गया। जो
किसी भी आपका
सिक्योरिटी टीम है, शॉप टीम है या आपके जो
नॉर्मल आईटी प्रोटेक्टर्स होते हैं जिनको
आईटी एडमिंस बोल सकते हो जो जिनको इनकी
थोड़ी बहुत नॉलेज है उनकी नजर में तुरंत आ
जाएगी ये चीज। ठीक है? उनकी नजर में ये
चीज तुरंत आ जाएगी। ठीक है? पॉइंट नंबर
वन। उसके बाद स्क्रिप्ट रन हुई। सीएमडी ने
भी बहुत सारी क्या की? कमांड का रन किया।
बहुत सारी टूल्स का यूज़ किया। उनके भी
क्या हुआ? सीएमडी के अंडर भी छोटे-छोटे सब
प्रोसेस क्रिएट हो गए। तो यह पूरा एक
सस्िशियस पार्ट हो गया। नेक्स्ट क्या हुआ?
दूसरी सबसे बड़ी चीज क्या हुई कि जब ये
स्क्रिप्ट ने अपना काम कंप्लीट कर लिया।
कंप्लीट करने के बाद ये स्क्रिप्ट कहां पर
सेव हुई? टेम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर। टेम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर सिस्टम ऑडिट रिपोर्टxt
के नाम से ये सेव हुई। तो जब टेम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर ये स्क्रिप्ट सेव हुई
तो इसके लिए भी एक सिस्टम एक इवेंट आईडी
जनरेट हुई जिसका नंबर था 11। इवेंट 11
इवेंट आईडी नंबर 11 मैं यह वो पार्ट बता
रहा हूं कि अगर आप डिफेंसिव साइड भी कभी
काम करोगे या आप एक ऑफेंसिव साइड काम कर
रहे हो तो आपने क्या-क्या गलतियां की है
ड्यूरिंग योर मशियस पे और डेवलपमेंट
क्योंकि जब आपको ये चीजें पता होंगी तो आप
एक अच्छे ऑफेंसिव साइडर भी बन सकते हो और
डिफेंसिव साइडर भी बन सकते हो क्योंकि
आपको दोनों दोनों नॉलेज मिल रही है। तो
क्या हुआ जब हुआ क्या है कि जब वह
इंफॉर्मेशन हार्वेस्टिंग कंप्लीट हो गई
उसके बाद क्या हुआ फ़ाइल को सेव किया गया
लोकल डायरेक्टरी के अंदर टेम डायरेक्टरी
के अंदर तो उसके लिए एक और इवेंट आईडी
जनरेट हुई 11
सोचो कि MS Word ऑन हुआ उसने सीएमडी की
प्रोसेस क्रिएट की सीएमडी के बाद हो क्या
रहा है एक और सिस्टम आईडी जनरेट हो रही है
सिस्टम आईडी नंबर एक और सॉरी इवेंट आईडी
11 जो क्या कर रही है एक फाइल को सेव कर
रही है पॉइंट नंबर नंबर टू था ये आपका
मिलसियस इवेंट का। उसके बाद ये थी आपकी
कौन सा फेज जहां पर क्या है कि इंफॉर्मेशन
हार्वेस्टिंग होने के बाद फाइल सेव होगी
आपके सिस्टम पर। नेक्स्ट आप सबको पता है।
फिर क्या किया कि जो MS Word था उसने पावर
सेल से कांटेक्ट किया। उसने पावर सेल से
कांटेक्ट किया और पावर सेल को ओपन किया।
तो चलो भैया अब इसके खाते में पावर सेल और
जुड़ गया। ठीक है? पावर शेलॉट exc नाम से
भी एक स्किप एक एक प्रोसेस और क्रिएट होगी
अगला स्पीशीज उसकी इवेंट आईडी क्या जनरेट
हुई 4104
4104 और पावर सेल ने क्या किया पावर सेल
ने सबसे पहले इस डेटा को रीड किया कोई
प्रॉब्लम नहीं डाटा को रीड कर सकती है
इसका कोई इवेंट जनरेट नहीं हुआ लेकिन
लेकिन जब उसने नेटवर्क कनेक्शन क्रिएट
किया रिवर्स कनेक्शन किसके साथ आपके काले
नेक्स्ट के साथ उसके लिए भी क्या हुआ? एक
इवेंट आईडी जनरेट हुई। इवेंट आईडी नंबर
थ्री। MS Word ने पहले सीएमडी ओपन की।
पॉइंट नंबर वन फ्लैग हुआ। उसके बाद पावर
सेल को ओपन किया। फ्लैग नंबर टू। पावर सेल
ने क्या किया? रिवर्स कनेक्शन बनाया
नेटवर्क के साथ। तो उसके लिए एक सिस्टम
आईडी इवेंट आईडी जनरेट हुई थ्री। तो ये
पॉइंट नंबर थ्री भी हो फ्लैग नंबर थ्री भी
हो गया। ठीक है? उसके बाद जैसे ही डेटा
एक्सफिल्ट्रेट हुआ एक और इवेंट जनरेट हुआ
कौन सा इवेंट आईडी 23 और 26 ये किसके लिए
जनरेट होती है जब कोई भी फाइल डिलीट होती
है तो कहने का मतलब मेरा यह है कि जब आपने
प्रीवियस क्लास में अपना पेलोड डेवलप किया
पेलोड डेवलप करने के बाद आपने उसको
एग्जीक्यूट करवाया एग्जीक्यूट करने के बाद
डेटा एक्सिल्ट्रेट किया आपने डेटा को
निकाला अपने काली लinक्स पर तो जो जो काम
आपने किया था आपके स्क्रिप्ट ने किया था
उसके लिए इतने इतने सारे फ्लैग जनरेट हुए।
किसके अंदर? आपके ब्लू टीमर्स के पास
टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर इतने सारे फ्लैग
जनरेट हुए। आप आप ही बताइए क्या यह एक
परफेक्ट पेड था? क्या यह एक परफेक्ट पेड
था?
मुझे नहीं लगता ये कोई परफेक्ट पेड था।
नहीं था ना? तो यही चीज क्या है? हम सीखने
वाले हैं कि एक परफेक्ट पेलोड और कैसे
बनाएं। इतने सारी इवेंट आईडी को कैसे कम
कर सकते हैं। ठीक है? आज हम इनमें से बहुत
सारी इवेंट आईडी को कम कर देंगे और कैसे
करेंगे? वो मैं आपको सिखाऊंगा। तो अभी
हमारे पास इसका भी अल्टरनेटिव है। इसका
अल्टरनेटिव ऑप्शन क्या है? वीबीएस
स्क्रिप्टिंग के केस में हम क्या कर सकते
हैं? डब्ल्यूएमआई का यूज़ कर सकते हैं।
किसका यूज़ कर सकते हैं? डब्ल्यूएमआई विंडो
मैनेजमेंट इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन इसका हम यूज कर
सकते हैं। इसका जो इंजन है इसके साथ हम
डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन बना सकते हैं। मतलब हम
क्या करेंगे? हम ना तो सीएमडी यूज़ करेंगे
ना हम कौन सी कमांड का ये एक्सटर्नल कमांड
होती है। मैं लिख देता हूं। wif
1 मिनट 1 मिनट। हां wmआईसी
ये नहीं रहेगा। wmic.exc
या यह कमांड यूज़ करते हैं ज्यादातर। तो,
हम क्या करेंगे? एक्सटर्नल कमांड यूज़ करने
के बजाय हम डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन किसके साथ
बनाएंगे? WMI के साथ। wmआई के साथ हम क्या
बनाएंगे? डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन बनाएंगे। तो,
इसको मैं थोड़ा सा क्या कर देता हूं? रब
कर देता हूं। ओके?
तो, अब ये डब्ल्यूएमआई होता क्या है? वैसे
तो मैं प्रीवियस क्लास में आपको बता चुका
हूं। डब्ल्यूएमआई होता क्या है? बट आई विल
एक्सप्लेन एक बार और। डब्ल्यूएमआई इज ए
बिल्ट इन टेक्नोलॉजी एंड मैनेजमेंट
फ्रेमवर्क विद इन द Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम दैट स्टोर मैनेज एंड कंट्रोल
इंफॉर्मेशन रिगार्डिंग एव्री हार्डवेयर
कंपोनेंट सॉफ्टवेयर पैकेज एंड सिस्टम
सेटिंग ऑन ए कंप्यूटर। कहने का मतलब क्या
है कि जो डब्ल्यूएमआई है Windows ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के अंदर एक ऐसी बिल्ट इन
टेक्नोलॉजी है या एक ऐसा मैनेजमेंट
फ्रेमवर्क है जो क्या करता है जो एक
कंप्यूटर के अंदर या जो एक कंप्यूटर के
अंदर हर एक हार्डवेयर सॉफ्टवेयर या जो
सिस्टम सेटिंग की इंफॉर्मेशन को स्टोर
मैनेज और कंट्रोल करता है। बेसिकली
डब्ल्यूएमआई के अंदर इस जो फ्रेमवर्क के
अंदर आपको आपके ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की सारी
इंफॉर्मेशन मिल जाती है। रिलेटेड टू द
सिस्टम सेटिंग, रिलेटेड टू द सॉफ्टवेयर
सेटिंग, रिलेटेड टू द हार्डवेयर सेटिंग।
ठीक है? बेसिकली आप क्या कर सकते हो? जो
डब्ल्यूएमआई है, आप उसको समझने के लिए हम
एक एनालॉजी को समझते हैं। एक चीज को
एग्जांपल लेते हैं। फॉर एग्जांपल कि जो
Windows ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम है, आपका एक बहुत
बड़ा घर है। ठीक है? और wmआई क्या है? उस
घर का कंट्रोल रूम है। ठीक है? अब अगर
आपको यह पता लगाना है कि आपके घर के अंदर
कितने फैन चल रहे हैं, कौन सी लाइट खराब
है। कौन किस रूम में रूम में गया है, कौन
किस रूम से बाहर आया है। तो ये चीज ये
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करने के लिए
आपको क्या है कि आपको भागदौड़ करने की
जरूरत नहीं है कि ओके मैं वहां से वहां
जाकर चेक करूंगा। नो बिकॉज़ क्योंकि आपके
पास कंट्रोल रूम है और कंट्रोल रूम में
आपके सीसीटीवीज है या कंट्रोल रूम में
आपके पास सारी इंफॉर्मेशन है उन सारी
मूवमेंट्स की उन सारी रिकॉर्ड्स की तो सेम
तरीके से जो डब्ल्यूएमआई है आपके ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम का कंट्रोल रूम है जिसके पास
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के बारे में वो सारी
जानकारी है जो आपको चाहिए तो अभी मैं क्या
कर रहा हूं मैं भाई डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन
बनाऊंगा किसके साथ डब्ल्यूएमआई के साथ मैं
इसके अलावा कुछ नहीं करने वाला मैं
डब्ल्यूएमआई के साथ डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन
बताऊंगा। ओके? तो डब्ल्यूएमआई काम कैसे
करता है? देखो एट इट्स कोर्स डब्ल्यूएमआई
लाइ ऑन ए सेंट्रल डेटाबेस कॉल्ड द सीआईएम
कॉमन इंफॉर्मेशनेशन मॉडल रिपॉजिटरी। ठीक
है? जो डब्ल्यूएमआई है इसके पीछे एक बहुत
बड़ा डेटाबेस काम करता है जो हर एक विंडोज
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर होता है। ठीक है?
जिसे हम क्या बोलते हैं? सीआईएम
रिपॉजिटरी। सीआईएम मतलब कॉमन इंफॉर्मेशन
मॉडल रिपोजिटरी। इसके अंदर क्या क्या है
कि जो रिपोजिटरी है इसके अंदर उस सारे
डेटा को क्लासेस की फॉर्म में ऑर्गेनाइज
किया गया है। सारे डेटा को क्लासेस के
डेटा के टाइप के हिसाब से क्लासेस की
फॉर्म में क्या किया गया? ऑर्गेनाइज किया
गया है। एंड टू एक्सेस दिस डेटा
डब्ल्यूएमआई लेवरेजेस द कॉम इंटरफेस। अगर
ये डेटा एक्सेस करना है डब्ल्यूएमआई को भी
वो क्या करता है? वो किसका यूज़ करता है?
कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़ करता है। किसका यूज़
करता है? कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल इंटरफ़ेस
का यूज़ करता है। जिसका हम भी यूज़ करने
वाले हैं विद द हेल्प ऑफ डब्ल्यूएमआई। तो
आई होप सबको कम क्लियर हो गया होगा कि
डब्ल्यूएमआई होता क्या है? अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन कि डब्ल्यूएमआई होता क्या है?
अंडरस्टुड?
अगर आप लोगों को डब्ल्यूएमआई समझ में आ
गया हो तो हम आगे बढ़ते हैं। तो नेक्स्ट
अब बात करते हैं हमारी ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी
पर्सपेक्टिव से। ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी
पर्सपेक्टिव से इन ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी
डब्ल्यूएमआई इज ए पावरफुल यूटिलिटी।
प्राइमरली ड्यू टू इट्स एबिलिटी टू एड इन
एडीआर इवजन।
बेसिकली अगर हम ऑफेंसिव साइड की बात करें,
हम ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी की बात करें तो जो
ऑफेंसिव सिक्योरिटी में डब्ल्यूएमआई सबसे
पावरफुल टूल माना जाता है। कैसे माना जाता
है? क्योंकि यह एडीआर इवेज में आपकी काफी
मदद कर सकता है और काफी मदद करता भी है।
कैसे? बिकॉज़ डब्ल्यूएमआई क्यूरीज
एग्जीक्यूट डायरेक्टली इन द मेमोरी वाया
कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट। एन अटैकर डज नॉट नीड टू
क्रिएट एक्सटर्नल कमांड लाइन बाइनरीज लाइक
cmdexc और wmआमcxe
कहने का मतलब क्या है कि जो डब्ल्यूएमआई
क्यूरीज है वो डायरेक्टली मेमोरी के अंदर
क्या करती हैं रन करती हैं एग्जीक्यूट
करती हैं वहीं से मेमोरी से डायरेक्ट डेटा
आपके पास आता है इसलिए अटैकर्स को क्या है
कोई भी एक्सटर्नल कमांड या एक्सटर्नल
टूल्स की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं होती यह डेटा
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए ये डेटा एक्स
फिल्ट्रेट करने के लिए एग्जीक्यूट करने के
लिए। ठीक है? कोई भी एक्सटर्नल प्रोसेस
क्रिएट करने की जरूरत नहीं है। दिस लीव्स
ए मिनिमम एग्जीक्यूशन फट फुटप्रिंट अलाउंग
रिकॉर्न टास्क टू बायपास ट्रेडिशनल
प्रोसेस मॉनिटरिंग। बेसिकली क्या है कि ये
आपको मिनिमम फुटप्रिंटिंग क्या करने के
लिए हेल्प करता है कि आपके जो है टारगेट
के ऊपर जब आप ये अभी हम क्या है? हम तो
रिकॉन ही करके दिखाएंगे। बिकॉज़ मैं कोई
मिलिशियस इंटेंट परफॉर्म नहीं करके
दिखाऊंगा। बट आप समझ लो कि हम रिकॉर्न कर
सकते हैं तो हम बाकी चीजें भी कर सकते
हैं। तो रिकॉर्न के टाइम में जब मैं इतनी
पावरफुल चीजों का यूज करूं तो आप ड्यूरिंग
योर प्रिलेज एस्केलेशन लेटरल मूवमेंट और
भी बहुत सारे पर्पस हो सकते हैं जिनका
थ्रू आप इनका यूज कर सकते हो। तो ये
बेसिकली क्या करता है जो आपके फुटप्रिंट
है जो इतनी सारी चीजें प्रीवियस पेलोड के
कारण जनरेट हुई थी। इतने सारे इवेंट जनरेट
हुए थे। हम हमने सोचा कि उन इवेंट को काफी
हद तक कैसे कम कर सकते हैं। तो आज हम उन
इवेंट्स को कुछ इवेंट्स को काफी हद तक कम
करने की कोशिश करेंगे। अभी हम क्या करने
वाले हैं ना तो कोई फाइल हम क्या करने
वाले हैं? सेव करने वाले जो हम क्या कर
रहे थे? इनेशन हार्वेस्टिंग कर रहे थे ना।
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन हार्वेस्टिंग करने के बाद
हमने क्या किया था कि जो हमारा ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम है ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के ऊपर ही एक
टेंपरेरी डायरेक्टरी थी या टेंपरेरी
फोल्डर है टेम फोल्डर विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम के केस में उसके अंदर हमने फाइल को
सेव किया था उसके बाद मैं पावर सेल से
उसको रीड कर रहा था। अब मैं क्या कर रहा
हूं? मैं डायरेक्टली मेमोरी के अंदर ही उस
डेटा को एक वेरिएबल में स्टोर करूंगा। उस
वेरिएबल से डायरेक्टली पावर सेल की हेल्प
से एक आध तो इवेंट जनरेट करेगा लेकिन इतने
सारे इवेंट जनरेट करने के बजाय हम कुछ
इवेंट कम करेंगे। तो हम पावर सेल की हेल्प
से क्या करेंगे? डायरेक्टली मेमोरी से उस
डेटा को आपकी अटैकर मशीन पर भेजेंगे। अभी
मैं वहां पर जो डेटा सेव करने का खेल चल
रहा था हमारे प्रीवियस स्क्रिप्ट में वो
नहीं करने वाला। तो चलो हम प्रैक्टिकली
देखते हैं। स्टार्ट करते हैं।
ये प्रीवियस पेलोड था। शायद आप सबको याद
है। तो इसमें एक चीज थी जो मे बी आपको
नहीं समझ में आई हो और मे बी हो सकता है
कि हां हमसे हुई थी। क्या हुआ था? किसी को
याद है कि जैसे हमने इनेबल कंटेंट किया था
तो हमने जिस पर्पस से वो एक पॉपअप बनाया
था हमने जिस पर्पस से वो एक इंफॉर्मेशन
वार्निंग बनाई थी वो वार्निंग सही से
एग्जीक्यूट नहीं हुई थी उसका एक कारण था
कारण ये था कि हमने उसके लिए कोड नहीं
लिखा था
हमने उसके लिए कोड नहीं लिखा था
नहीं लिखा था ना हमने तो आज हम वो कोड भी
लिखेंगे और अपना भी कोड लिखेंगे तो चलो
फिर हम इसको थोड़ा सा मॉडिफाई करते हैं
पूरे कोड को ठीक है करें मॉडिफाई तो देखो
बाकी ये एज इट इज रहेगा ऑप्शन एक्सप्लसिट
हम एज इट इज यूज़ करने वाले हैं उसके बाद
ये ऑटो एग्जीक्यूशन ट्रिगर्स है प्राइवेट
सब डॉक्यूमेंट ओपन अभी अभी इसको अभी के
लिए इसको हम हटा देते हैं क्योंकि हमें
नहीं पता अभी हम वाले फंक्शन का नाम क्या
रहेगा ये एज इट इज़ रख लेते हैं। ये भी एज
इट इज़ रख लेते हैं क्योंकि प्रीवियस क्लास
वाला है। अभी इस कमेंट को हम चेंज कर लेते
हैं। कमेंट क्या है? तो अभी हम कमेंट को
चेंज कर लेते हैं। हमारा
हम लिख देते हैं अभी स्टिल टेक्निक वन।
टेक्निक
0 1 ओके तो बाकी सारी चीजें एज इट इज़ रहने
देते हैं। तो अभी मैं इसको कर देता हूं
इसमें से सब कुछ डिलीट लगभग लगभग मैं
डिलीट करता हूं। फिर से क्रिएट कर लेंगे
ताकि आपको कंफ्यूजन ना हो और आपको चीजें
क्लियर रहे। तो डिलीट कर दिया। फंक्शन का
नाम हम अभी सेम रख लेते हैं। सही रहेगा।
चलो फंक्शन नाम भी हम सेम रख लेते हैं और
इस फंक्शन को हम क्या कर देंगे अभी कॉल भी
कर देते हैं। चलो ज्यादा टेंशन नहीं लेंगे
हम अभी। सो कॉल कर देते हैं इस फंक्शन को।
हम कॉल कर देते हैं।
इस फंक्शन को हमने क्या कर दिया? कॉल भी
कर दिया। चलो बहुत अच्छी बात है। और यहां
पर भी इस फंक्शन को भी हम क्या कर देते
हैं? कॉल कर देते हैं। चलो अच्छी बात है।
मे बी यहां तक सब कुछ सही है। अभी हम सबसे
पहले क्या कर रहे हैं? जो हमारा फंक्शनंस
है इस फंक्शन से भी पहले हम कुछ करने वाले
हैं। वो हम क्या करने वाले हैं? हम सबसे
पहले एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट करेंगे। एक ग्लोबल
वेरिएबल क्रिएट कर लेंगे। यहां पर कैसे?
मैं इसको नीचे कर देता हूं। नेक्स्ट सबको
दिखाई दे रहा है? स्क्रीन पर मेबी सबको
दिखाई दे रहा है।
नहीं मालवेयर एनालिसिस कॉस्ट नहीं ब्रो हम
क्या कर रहे हैं? डीए की सीरीज में ही
हमने क्या सीखा हुआ है? हमने सीखा है
क्लाइंट सेट अटैक्स। क्लाइंट सेट अटैक्स
में हम क्या पढ़ रहे हैं? हमने वीबीए
डेवलपमेंट सीखा था। वीबीए के अंदर मैं
आपको सिखाया था कि मालवेयर कैसे डेवलप किए
जाएंगे। तो मालवेयर डेवलप करना सिखा रहा
हूं। बेसिकली पेलोड डेवलप करना सिखा रहा
हूं वि दी हेल्प ऑफ ए वीवीबीए। मै के पेड
डेवलप करना सिखा रहा हूं।
तो चलिए फिर हम एक काम करते हैं। अभी हम
बाद में बात करेंगे दोस्त। इसके बाद हम
क्या करते हैं? रिपोर्ट
डेटा
एज स्ट्रिंग।
एक ग्लोबल वेरिएबल क्रिएट कर लेते हैं हम।
सो दैट कि क्योंकि इसमें थोड़ा कोड बहुत
लंबा होने वाला है। ठीक? एक हेल्पफर
फंक्शन क्रिएट कर लेते हैं। अभी हेलपर
फंक्शन क्रिएट करने के लिए कमेंट दे लेते
हैं हम। तो यह हमारा
अलफर फंक्शन
फंक्शन के लिए कमेंट है और अलफर फंक्शन भी
हम कैसे करने वाले हैं देखो
प्राइवेट एंड
सब
ऐड लाइन उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे
वाई वी एल
टी ई एक्स टेक्स्ट एच स्ट्रिंग
[संगीत]
एक वेट वेट वेट भैया क्या हो गया? कर रहा
हूं कर रहा हूं। कर रहा हूं कर रहा हूं।
ओके और ये हमने एक फंक्शन क्रिएट कर लिया
ऐड लाइन बाय ये उस जिसके अंदर हम क्या
करने वाले हैं? एज ए पैरामीटर टेक्स्ट
लेने वाले हैं। तो चलो फिर वेरिएबल को यूज़
करते हैं हम।
रिपोर्ट यह तो आप सबको पता चल गया ना कैसे
लिखते हैं हमें? वेरिएबल्स आप सबको क्रिएट
करने आ गए। रिपोर्ट इक्व रिपोर्ट डाटा
रिपोर्ट डाटा
बोलना क्लास खत्म होने के बाद बोलना ठीक
है आई विल वेट कार्तिक
तो ये रहा कहां गए हम रिपोर्ट डेटा उसके
बाद हम क्या करने हैं इसमें कंकटिनेशन
टेक्स्ट कंकटिनेशन
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़]
और वीबी सीआरएलएफ ये क्या है अ आपके इसका
मतलब मतलब ये है कि कैरिज रिटर्न नहीं है।
मतलब क्या है कि जो इसके जो भी डेटा स्टोर
हो रहा है जैसे कि यहां पर रिपोर्ट यहां
पर एक डेटा आ गया। उसके बाद अ हर बार
इसमें अपेंड होगा और नई लाइन में अपेंड
होगा। नई लाइन में अपेंड होगा। चलो ये है
हमारा एक फंक्शन। अभी इसके बाद हम एक
कमेंट दे देते हैं। हमारा मेन फंक्शन मेन
रिकॉन फंक्शन।
मेन रिकॉर्न फंक्शन से पहले हमें कुछ और
काम करना था जो मैंने अभी तक
इसमें मे बी नॉट एज
जो मुझे लिखना था वेट वेट वेट गाइस जस्ट
वन मिनट
आपके लिए कोड मैंने कहीं पर ओके ओके ओके
वेट वेट वेट मैंने कहां लिखा था अंडरस्टुड
अभी याद आ गया मुझे
तो मैंने कोड लिखा है अपनी एक पे
इसके अंदर
वेज माय टीxt फाइल
एंड एंड यह रहा तो मैंने लिखा था आपके लिए
ये रहा ये रहा आपका वो कोड मैं आपको समझा
ये कोड है वो जो आपके लिए जरूरी था और आज
हम इसको एक्सप्लेन नहीं करेंगे। हम अगली
क्लास में एक्सप्लेन कर दूंगा मैं बट
क्योंकि अभी मुझे और कुछ समझाना आपको तो
इजी रहेगा। चलो हम चलते हैं। फिर हमारे
एक्सप्लेन करने की वैसी खास जरूरत तो नहीं
होनी चाहिए। बट हम इसको कहां यूज़ करेंगे?
यहीं कर लेते हैं मेन फंक्शन से पहले। तो
हम यूज़ करते हैं इसको हमारा
नॉर्मल फंक्शन के तो। ये रहा पेस्ट कर
दिया हमने एक और। तो यहां पर है अनहाइड
कैंडिडेट। तो यहां पर मैं इसको अ हटा देता
हूं। अनहाइड
अनहाइड
अनहाइड लिख देता हूं। ठीक है? अनहाइड तो
यहां सिर्फ ओनली अनहाइड और मैं इसको कॉल
करूंगा कहां पर? अनहाइड फंक्शन है ना? तो
मैं इसको यहां पर कॉल करूंगा।
कॉल
अनहाइड फंक्शन। यहां पर हमने कॉल कर दिया।
और यहां पर भी देखेंगे कॉल करके। वी
रिक्वायर्ड
कॉल अनहाइड फंक्शन।
गुड। इसमें क्या किया हमने? एक वेरिएबल
यहां पर जो हमने क्या किया था जिसको हाइड
किया था टेक्स्ट को यहां पर हाइड कर देंगे
और यहां पे एक पॉप अप आएगा हार्डवेयर
सिक्योरिटी टोकन वेरीिफाइड ग्लोबल बैंक ये
आप देख लोगे इसका रिएक्शन तो अभी हम आ
जाते हैं अपने मेन फंक्शन पे ठीक है तो
मेन फंक्शन के लिए हम एक कमेंट देते हैं
हमारे मेन
रिकॉन
रिकॉन स्क्रिप्ट मेन रिकॉन स्क्रिप्ट
मेन रिकॉन स्क्रिप्ट ठीक है यह हमारी थी।
अभी हम क्या हमारे फ़ंक्शन का नाम क्या है?
इनिशिएट
फुल रिकॉन। चलिए अभी इसके लिए भी हमें
क्या करना पड़ेगा? कई वेरिएबल्स डिफाइन
करने पड़ेंगे। तो हम सबसे पहले कई
वेरिएबल्स को डिफाइन कर लेता हूं। उसके
बाद वन बाय वन सारे वेरिएबल्स को हम यूज़
करेंगे। चलो चलो फिर कॉइन
स्ट्रिंग ओके गुड।
बहुत बड़ा कोड होने वाला है। आप सोचोगे
बोलो सर यह इतने बड़े कोड भी हम लिखने लगे
नेटवर्क एज ऑब्जेक्ट
कोई प्रॉब्लम थी नहीं है किसी को बता देना
मेरे को
ऑब्जेक्ट
ओके पहला भी हमारा स्प्रिंग नहीं ऑब्जेक्ट
किसी को कोई प्रॉब्लम हो तो बता देना मेरे
को।
समझ लेंगे हम इसको।
सबको क्लास समझ में आ रही है ना? वैसे
किसी के लिए हार्ड तो नहीं पड़ रही?
ऐसी चीजें कहीं पर नहीं मिलने वाली। भाई
मैं एक चीज बता देता हूं।
ऐसी चीजें आपको नहीं मिलने वाली। कोई नहीं
देगा आपको
ऑब्जेक्ट
डम
आइटम ऑब्जेक्ट
कहीं नहीं मिलने वाली पूरी YouTube पे
कहीं पे सर्च कर लेना ये वाली क्लासेस तो
नहीं मिलने वाली आपको बाकी सब मिल जाएगा
देन देन देन देन ओके हम अभी ही अपने सारे
आईपी एड्रेस के लिए भी अटैकर आईपी एज
स्ट्रिंग
स्ट्रिंग उसके बाद टिम मैं एक काम कर लेता
हूं आप लोगों के लिए इसको बार-बार वो ना
करे करना पड़े
अटैक कर कोड
स्ट्रिंग अटैक डी सी के ई आर पी ओ आर डी
ओके देन एक काम करता हूं मैं इसमें ऐसे कर
देता हूं ताकि आपको समझ में आ जाए
उसके बाद नेक्स्ट एक और दो और वेरिएबल
क्रिएट करूंगा मैं और सारे वेरिएबल हमारे
यूज़ हो जाएंगे। अगर नहीं पता तो यूज़ हो
जाएंगे।
एक्स फिल्ट्रेट
पीएस एक्स
पीएस एक्स फिल्ट्रेट एज
स्ट्रिंग याद आ गई ये किस चीज के लिए हम
यूज़ कर रहे हैं मे बी आपको पता होगा उसके
बाद
स्किप रिपोर्ट
स्ट्रीम [संगीत]
ओके
एस्केप रिपोर्ट चलो गुड ये हो गया अभी हम
एक काम करेंगे अभी हम कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट्स का
क्या करेंगे इनिशलाइजेशन करेंगे तो चलो
फिर हम क्या करेंगे कॉम ऑब्जेक्ट
इनिशियलाइजेशन
अभी चलो फिर सेट
दैट ऑब्जेक्ट
ये हो गया। देन
सेट
नेटवर्क। अब नेटवर्क के लिए भी हमें यहां
एक यूज़ करना पड़ेगा। डब्ल्यू स्क्रिप्ट
उसके लिए भी होती है।
चलो यह एक और चीज है अभी
तो जैसे कि मैंने आपको एक चीज बताई थी हम
किसके साथ कम्युनिकेशन करने वाले हैं
डब्ल्यूएमआईसी मतलब डब्ल्यूएमआई windows
मैनेजमेंट इंस्ट्रूमेंट के साथ हम
कम्युनिकेशन करने वाले हैं। बट सवाल यही
उठता है कि कम्युनिकेशन कैसे करेंगे? उसको
समझाऊंगा बाद में। पहले उसको समझा देता
हूं। बाद में यहां पर हम यूज़ करेंगे। अभी
हम आ गए अपने एक्चुअल कांसेप्ट पर कि जो
हम आज का कांसेप्ट पढ़ने वाले हैं और काफी
अ लॉन्ग कोड बनने वाला है। ठीक है? ये ऐसा
नहीं कि आप जस्ट ऐसा ही है। नहीं टाइम पास
के लिए नहीं होने वाला बिल्कुल भी। तो हम
बात करते हैं अभी हम कैसे क्या करेंगे? हम
जो WMआई है Windows मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन के साथ डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन
कैसे बना सकते हैं? जो WMI है उसके साथ हम
डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन कैसे बना सकते हैं?
ठीक है? डब्ल्यूएमआईसी इंजन के साथ हम
डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन कैसे बना सकते हैं? वह
बात करते हैं। तो उसके लिए हम यूज़ करेंगे
किसका? इसका।
उसके लिए यूज़ करेंगे हम एक ऑब्जेक्ट का
यूज़ करेंगे। गेट ऑब्जेक्ट। उसके बाद ये इस
तरीके से। इस पूरे एक ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़
करेंगे। एक इंस्टेंस का यूज़ करेंगे। ठीक
है? उसके लिए हम किसका यूज़ करेंगे? इस
ऑब्जेक्ट का यूज़ करेंगे। ये ऑब्जेक्ट क्या
कर रहा है? इसके बारे में आपको बता देता
हूं। गेट ऑब्जेक्ट क्या है? गेट ऑब्जेक्ट
इज ए बिल्ट इन प्रोग्रामिंग फंक्शन यूज टू
एक्सेस एक्टिव कॉम ऑटोमेशन ऑब्जेक्ट्स एंड
सिस्टम सर्विस डायरेक्टली। सिस्टम सर्विस
डायरेक्टली मतलब क्या है कि जो गेट
ऑब्जेक्ट है ये एक बिल्ट इन फंक्शन होता
है। क्या करने के लिए? आपके सिस्टम के
अंदर जो एक्टिव ऑब्जेक्ट्स होते हैं, जो
सिस्टम सर्विज हैं, उनका एक्सेस लेने के
लिए हम किसका यूज़ करते हैं? गेट ऑब्जेक्ट
का। किसका यूज़ करते हैं? हम गेट ऑब्जेक्ट
का यूज करते हैं। उसके बाद यह यह वाला जो
पैरामीटर है यह वाला यह क्या करता है?
इसके बारे में बात थे। इट डायरेक्ट द
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम टू रूट द रिक्वेस्ट थ्रू
द डब्ल्यूएमआई मैनेजमेंट नेम स्पेस।
बेसिकली यह Windows को बताता है कि भाई जो
मेरा ट्रैफिक है उसको डब्ल्यूएमआई
मैनेजमेंट लाइब्रेरी के थ्रू पास करो। या
मैं क्या क्या चाहता हूं कि मैं बेसिकली
यह बताता है Windows को कि मैं
डब्ल्यूएमआई मैनेजमेंट नेम स्पेस के साथ
क्या करना चाहता हूं? बातचीत करना चाहता
हूं या उसके अंदर एंटर करना चाहता हूं।
ओके? मैं उसके साथ एंटर करना चाहता हूं।
ये बोल सकते हो। डायरेक्ट द ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम टू राउट द रिक्वेस्ट थ्रू द
डब्ल्यूएमआई मैनेजमेंट स्पेस। बेसिकली मैं
जो डब्ल्यूएमआई मैनेजमेंट नेम स्पेस है
उसके अंदर क्या करना चाहता हूं? एंटर करना
चाहता हूं। ठीक है? आप उसके अंदर एंटर तक
कर जाओगे। उसके बाद कहां पर जाना है आपको?
ठीक है? मैं आपको एंट्री दे दूंगा। मैंने
इस कंपनी में आपको इस ऑर्गेनाइजेशन में
एंट्री दे दी। बस आपको किसी पर्टिकुलर
डिपार्टमेंट, किसी स्पेसिफिक लाइब्रेरी
कहीं पर तो जाना होगा ना। वो चीज हम यहां
पर मेंशन करते हैं। इसके बाद यहां पर दिख
रहा है। ये आपको पाथ टाइप से दिखाई दे रहा
होगा।
डबल बैकस्ल डॉट बैकस्ल रूट बैक स्लैश ये
नाम अजीब सा नाम आपको दिखाई दे रहा होगा।
ठीक है? ये अजीब सा नाम आपको दिखाई दे रहा
होगा। तो यह क्या करता है? इट स्पेसिफाई द
टारगेट पाथ। यहां पर हम क्या करते हैं?
इसके बाद इस वर्ड के बाद हम मेंशन करते
हैं पाथ। ठीक है? हम टारगेट का पाथ कि
भैया मुझे एक काम करना है कि डब्ल्यू एमआई
मैनेजमेंट के अंदर एंटर करने के बाद मुझे
इस पर्टिकुलर लोकेशन पर जाना है। तो इस
पर्टिकुलर पाथ पर जाना है। तो वो
पर्टिकुलर पाथ हम यहां पर मेंशन करते हैं।
यहां पर जो डॉट है वो डॉट क्या करता है?
वो डॉट रिप्रेजेंट करता है आपकी लोकल मशीन
को और रूट और ये चीज जो आपको सीआईएम वी2
ये क्या करता है? ये आपकी डेटाबेस
रिपोजिटरी है। ये आपकी प्राइमरी डेटाबेस
रिपोजिटरी है। जहां पर क्या है? आपके जो
विंडोज सिस्टम का सारा हार्डवेयर,
सॉफ्टवेयर और सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन डेट
स्टोर है। बेसिकली क्या है कि इस लाइन का
मतलब है कि आप ही की लोकल मशीन में कहां
पर इस रेपोजिटरी के अंदर मैं क्या करना
चाहता हूं? आपके जो
[गला साफ़ करने की आवाज़] हार्डवेयर जो
सॉफ्टवेयर जो सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन का जो
डाटा स्टोर है मैं उसको एक्सेस करना चाहता
हूं। मैंने क्या किया? यह चीज मेंशन की
अपनी स्क्रिप्ट में। स्क्रिप्ट में मेंशन
करके मैंने भेज दी टारगेट सिस्टम के पास।
अब टारगेट सिस्टम के लिए ये एक क्या बोल
सकते हो? कमांड है कि भैया आप ही के
सिस्टम में आप ही की इस डेटाबेस रिपोजिटरी
के अंदर मुझे जो हार्डवेयर सॉफ्टवेयर और
सिस्टम कॉन्फ़िगरेशन का जो डेटा है उसको
एक्सेस करना है। मुझे इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए।
बेसिकली ये ऑब्जेक्ट क्या काम करता है?
व्हेन वी इनिशिएट दिस ऑब्जेक्ट इट
एस्टैब्लिश ए डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन विद द
डब्ल्यूएमआई इंजन। जब आप इस ऑब्जेक्ट को
यूज करते हो तो ये क्या करता है कि जो
डब्ल्यूएमआई इंजन है उसके साथ क्या करता
है? डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन उसके साथ डायरेक्ट
कनेक्शन बनाता है। किसके साथ? डब्ल्यूएमआई
इंजन के साथ। ठीक है? जो आपका wmआई इंजन
है उसके साथ डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन बनाता है।
एंड दिस ऑपरेशन डज़ नॉट रिक्वायर
स्पैमिंग एनी न्यू एक्सटर्नल प्रोसेस।
मतलब अब इस ऑपरेशन में आपको ना तो कोई
एक्सटर्नल प्रोसेस क्रिएट करने की जरूरत,
ना कोई एक्सटर्नल कमांड यूज़ करने की
जरूरत। बिकॉज़ वी लीवरेज कंपोनेंट कॉम
ऑटोमेशन एंड द स्क्रिप्ट कम्युनिकेट
डायरेक्टली विद द ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम। कहने
का मतलब क्या है? कि यहां पे हम क्या कर
रहे हैं? जो कंपोनेंट ऑब्जेक्ट मॉडल
ऑटोमेशन टेक्निक है, उसका यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
और ये टेक्निक क्या कर रही है? ये सीधा
मेमोरी के अंदर जो ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के साथ
कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश कर रही है। मेमोरी
के अंदर
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम के अंदर डायरेक्ट
कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश कर रही है। ठीक
है? डायरेक्ट कम्युनिकेशन इस्टैब्लिश कर
रही है। अंडरस्टुड? ये चीज सबको समझ में आ
गई? तो इसीलिए मैं आपको बता देता हूं। जब
भी कोई अटैकर या जब भी हम अपनी स्क्रिप्ट
में कैट ऑब्जेक्ट जैसे फंक्शन का यूज़ करते
हैं तो बेसिकली उसका सीधा मतलब क्या है?
कि हम चाहते हैं कि मैं कोई भी एक्सटर्नल
प्रोसेस क्रिएट नहीं करना चाहता। मैं
डायरेक्ट सीधा मेमोरी से उस डेटा को फैच
करना चाहता हूं। अब इससे होगा क्या कि जो
सिक्योरिटी मॉनिटरिंग टूल्स है उनको जल्दी
से नहीं पता चलता क्योंकि
क्योंकि सिस्टम में कोई भी नई प्रोसेस
क्रिएट नहीं हुई। क्योंकि जब तक कोई
सिस्टम में नई प्रोसेस क्रिएट नहीं होती
उसका इवेंट जनरेट नहीं होगा। इवेंट जनरेट
नहीं होगा तो उसके डिटेक्शन के चांसेस
थोड़े से कम हो जाते हैं। पूरी तरह
नेग्लिक नहीं हुआ क्योंकि इतनी एडवांस
टेक्निक नहीं है ये। बट जो पिछला पेलोड
आपने बनाया था वो मान के चलो कि आप उस
पेलोड को आप 2000 2002 के टाइम में या
2006 के टाइम में यूज़ करते तो दैट वाज़ द
बेस्ट पेलोड। लेकिन 2026 में उस पेलोड को
यूज करोगे तो आपसे बड़ा कोई मूर्ख नहीं
क्योंकि सेम टाइम पकड़े जाओगे विद इन
फ्रिक्शन ऑफ सेकंड जैसे वो एंटर क्लिक
करेगा आपका डिफेंडर ही आपकी बैंड बजा देगा
अंडरस्टुड वो डिफेंडर ही क्या करेगा आपकी
बैंड बजा देगा तो चलो फिर हम एक काम करते
अभी फॉर एग्जांपल एक अगर आपको ये चीज समझ
में नहीं आई होगी तो मैं एक एग्जांपल और
समझाता हूं फॉर एग्जांपल कि आपको क्या
करना है आपको अपने स्कूल के अंदर
प्रिंसिपल ऑफिस से कोई रिकॉर्ड चाहिए।
आपको आपके स्कूल के अंदर प्रिंसिपल ऑफिस
से कोई रिकॉर्ड चाहिए और वो रिकॉर्ड आपको
अनऑफिशियली चाहिए। मतलब आपको वो क्या करना
है? चुराना है। तो वो रिकॉर्ड लेने के लिए
आपके पास दो ऑप्शन है। पहला ऑप्शन क्या
है? कि आप बाहर से किसी मैसेंजर को
बुलाओगे। ठीक है? या किसी मैसेंजर को
भेजोगे। वो क्या करेगा? आपके लिए वो फाइल
चुराएगा। वो रिकॉर्ड चुराएगा। अब जिससे
क्या होगा? सभी का ध्यान जितना भी
मैनेजमेंट स्टाफ है, जितने भी लोग हैं,
सबका ध्यान उस मैचेंजर की तरफ जाएगा ही
जाएगा। दूसरा ऑप्शन आपके पास क्या है?
दूसरा ऑप्शन क्या है कि आप खुद चुपचाप
प्रिंसिपल ऑफिस में जाओगे। उस कैबिनेट को
ओपन करोगे उस कैबिनेट की चाबी से जो
प्रिंसिपल ऑफिस में ही होगी। कैबिनेट को
ओपन करके उस फाइल को उठाओगे और चुरा लिए
जाओगे। ठीक है? ना किसी को पता चला। ठीक
है? और चुपचाप आपने फाइल भी चुरा ली। आपका
काम भी हो गया। तो अभी जो पहला तरीका था
पहला तरीका में सबको पता चल गया कि कोई
बाहर से आया प्रिंसिपल ऑफिस में गया और
फाइल चुरा कर ले गया और दूसरा तरीका जो
आपने यूज़ किया वो क्या था कि बाहर से कोई
आया ही नहीं ठीक है और किसी को कानों कान
खबर भी नहीं मिली और आपका काम भी हो गया
अंडरस्टुड तो हम कौन सा तरीका यूज़ करने
वाले हैं अभी दूसरा तरीका क्योंकि जो
फर्स्ट इससे पहले जो क्लास में क्लास नंबर
81 में हमने जो तरीका यूज़ किया था वह
तरीका था कि हमने बाहर से किसी मैसेंजर को
बुलाया। वह आया सिस्टम में फाइल चुराकर
गया और अपने ट्रेसेस छोड़कर चला गया। बट
अभी मैं क्या चाहता हूं कि उन ट्रेसेस को
कम करना चाहता हूं। अंडरस्टुड गाइस?
अंडरस्टुड?
तो चलिए फिर हम इसको भी प्रैक्टिकल लेते
हैं। तो हम इसको कैसे यूज़ कर सकते हैं?
उसकी बात करते हैं। अब हम इसको भी कैसे
यूज़ कर सकते हैं? इस पे आ जाते हैं। तो
इसको यूज़ करने के लिए हम हमेशा के लिए हम
क्या करने वाले हैं? एक वेरिएबल क्रिएट
करने वाले हैं। वेरिएबल में इसका क्या
रेफरेंस क्रिएट कर रेफरेंस सेव करने वाले
हैं। तो हम यहां पर एक वेरिएबल हमने
क्रिएट किया था डब्ल्यूएमआई सर्विस के नाम
से। डब्ल्यूएमआई
सर्विस। मैं इसको वेरिएबल को क्या कर लेता
हूं? इधर कॉपी कर लेता हूं। ओके।
यह रहा इसको कॉपी करता हूं। इसके अंदर मैं
गेट ऑब्जेक्ट
एंड
ये रहा। उसके बाद
डब्ल्यू आई एन एम जी एमटीएस एम जी एम टी
एस
एंड हमें पाथ मेंशन करना है।
ओके ये हो गया नेक्स्ट हिट एंटर तो यहां
पे हमने किसका रेफरेंस सेव कर लिया यहां
पर हमने रेफरेंस सेव किया किसका wmआई के
साथ हमने हमने यहां पे क्या बनाया कनेक्शन
कनेक्शन विद
डब्ल्यूएम
इंजन
WMI इंजन के साथ हमने डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन
बना लिया।
ठीक है? यहां पर हमने डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन
बना लिया। चलो गुड। डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन भी
बन गया हमारा। कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है।
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं। अभी नेक्स्ट अभी हमें
क्या करना है? अभी एज ए एज ए रेटिमर एज ए
सिक्योरिटी टेस्टर। सबसे पहले आपको कौन सी
इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए? बताओ। सबसे पहले आपको
कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए?
सबसे पहले आपको कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए?
एज ए रेड टिंबर एज ए सिक्योरिटी रजिस्टर
आपको सबसे पहले कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए
होती है? बताइए।
बिल्कुल। आपको सबसे पहले टारगेट मशीन के
बारे में इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए होती है कि कौन
सा ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम कौन सा बिल्ट वर्जन चल
रहा है। क्यों चाहिए? ताकि आप उसके हिसाब
से आगे के एक्सप्लइट या जो स्क्रिप्ट्स
हैं वो प्लान कर सकें। ठीक है? तो इसके
लिए भी हम क्या करते हैं? इसके लिए
डब्ल्यूएमआई के अंदर इसके इसके लिए
डब्ल्यूएमआई के अंदर डब्ल्यूएमआई मतलब
Windows मैनेजमेंट इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन के
अंदर पहले से ही एक बिल्ट इन क्लास होती
है। उस क्लास का नाम क्या है? विंड 32
ओपनिंग सिस्टम। यह क्लास रहती है क्योंकि
जब आपने डब्ल्यूएमआई का इंजन के साथ
डायरेक्ट कनेक्शन बना लिया उसके बाद मैंने
आपको एक डेटाबेस का नाम बताया था। उस
डेटाबेस में यह क्लास होती है। ठीक है? वो
इंफॉर्मेशन देने के लिए जो आपको चाहिए।
ठीक है? विद इन विंडोज मैनेजमेंट
इंस्ट्रूमेंटेशन देयर इज ए प्रीबिल्ट
नेटिव क्लास नोन एज विन 32 ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम। हम इसकी हेल्प से क्या कर सकते
हैं? जब इस क्लास को हम यूज़ करते हैं। इस
क्लास को यूज़ करने से ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
तुरंत समझा समझ जाता है कि जो आपका जो जो
यूजर इसको यूज़ कर रहा है उसको क्या है कि
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम लेवल की कोड इंफॉर्मेशन
चाहिए। और इससे हम क्या-क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल सकते हैं? इससे हम इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल
सकते हैं। ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का नाम,
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का वर्जन, उसकी
आर्किटेक्चर, उसके ऊपर उसका रजिस्टर्ड
यूजर। कौन सा रजिस्टर्ड यूज़र्स?
जिसने जिस यूजर ने उस लाइसेंस को यूज किया
हुआ है। जिस यूजर ने वो लाइसेंस लिया है।
उसके बाद इंस्टॉल डेट या ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
कब इंस्टॉल किया गया था? तो ये एक
लाइब्रेरी है। ये एक क्लास है। इस क्लास
की हेल्प से आप ये पांच इनेशन निकाल सकते
हो। छठी नहीं निकाल सकते। ठीक है? इस
क्लास की हेल्प से आप ये पांच इनेशन निकाल
सकते हो। कौन सी? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का नाम,
वर्जन का नाम, कौन सा वर्जन यूज़ हो रहा
है? उसकी आर्किटेक्चर क्या है? और उसका
रजिस्टर यूजर क्या है? उसकी इंस्टॉल डेट
क्या है? अब इसको हम कैसे यूज कर सकते
हैं? इसके लिए मैंने पहले से ही एक
स्क्रिप्ट लिखी हुई है क्योंकि आपका टाइम
बचाना है क्योंकि एक से सवा घंटे की क्लास
में इतना नहीं लिख सकते। वो स्क्रिप्ट है
आपकी कहां पर? सॉरी एक और काम करना रह गया
हमारा स्क्रिप्ट में हमें
क्या करना था? यह यूज करने से पहले हमें
कुछ और डाटा यहां पर यूज करना है। तो मुझे
बस थोड़ा सा टाइम दीजिए स्क्रिप्ट को
क्योंकि हमें जो वेरिएबल बनाया था ना तो
हमें इसके जस्ट बाद एक डेटा ऐड करना था।
ये रहा इसको अब समझा देता हूं। ये क्या
है? मतलब एक कोड कोड लिखना था। हमने कौन
क्यों लिखना था वो आपको बता देता हूं।
क्योंकि हमें रिपोर्ट चाहिए ना। तो
रिपोर्ट के लिए हमें एक कोड चाहिए। यहां
पर बिल्कुल सही है। इसी के नीचे ही आना
था। ये रहा। यहां पर हमने क्या किया?
रिपोर्ट डेटा वेरिएबल्स था ऑलरेडी वहां पर
हमने यूज़ किया हुआ है और इसको हम क्या
करने वाले हैं अभी रिपोर्ट डेटा वेरिएबल्स
एज अ स्ट्रिंग इसको मैं अभी मे बी इट्स
राइट और रोंग आई ट्राई टू अंडरस्टैंड नाउ
गुड
यहां पर हम क्या करते हैं इसको डिलीट कर
देते हैं क्योंकि इसको हम ऑलरेडी क्रिएट
कर चुके हैं वेरिएबल को ग्लोबल वेरिएबल
यहां पर अभी हमने क्या किया जो रिपोर्ट
डेटा वेरिएबल्स है उसको सबसे पहले सेट
किया एंप्टी उसके बाद हमने हमने क्या
किया? रिपोर्ट डेटा वेरिएबल के अंदर। उसके
बाद हम क्या कर रहे हैं? अभी रिपोर्ट डेटा
वेरिएबल नहीं यूज़ करने वाले। हम यहां ये
यूज़ करेंगे। हम हम यहां पर हमने गलत चीज
यूज़ की है। यहां पर हम यूज़ करेंगे इसका।
एंड ये रहा
हम
इज़ माय प्राइवेट फंक्शन। यह रहा ऐड लाइन।
यूज़ कर रहा हूं मैं ऐड लाइन। ठीक है? तो
यहां पर यूज़ किया ऐड लाइन।
हेडलाइन के बाद मैं यहां पर कर रहा हूं।
उसके बाद मेरा
ऐड लाइन के बाद तुरंत यह
टेक्स्ट
ऐड लाइन के बाद तुरंत ये टेक्स्ट मैं ऐड
कर रहा हूं। ओके? तुरंत ये टेक्स्ट मैं ऐड
कर रहा हूं। मुझे इसको ऐड करने की जरूरत
नहीं है। उसके बाद सेम
क्योंकि हेडलाइन मेरा क्या है? एक फंक्शन
है। हेडलाइन मेरा क्या है? एक फंक्शन है।
ओके। इसलिए इसको भी मैं क्या कर देता हूं?
रिमूव कर देता हूं।
यहां पे मेरा एक हेडलाइन क्या है? एक
फंक्शन है।
यहां पे ये सब यूज़ करने की जरूरत नहीं है।
क्यों यूज़ करने की जरूरत नहीं है। बिकॉज़
यहां पर आप यूज़ कर सको इसके अंदर। देखो ये
रहा। जो भी टेक्स्ट आएगा ना इस ऐड लाइन के
अंदर। यह रहा। जो भी टेक्स्ट आएगा यहां पर
सेव होगा। यहां पर सेव होगा। टेक्स्ट यहां
पर इसलिए हम यूज़ कर रहे हैं।
जी मैं आपको भेजूंगा ये भेज दूंगा। हमारे
उस ग्रुप में भेज दूंगा। ओके हमारे उस
ग्रुप में भेज दूंगा। अच्छी बात आपने याद
दिलाया। मैं यही तो वेट कर रहा था ना कि
आप कितने एक्टिव हो। मुझे खुद याद है सब
कुछ। आपकी एक्टिविटी एक्टिवनेस मुझे चेक
करनी होती है कि आप कितने एक्टिव हो। तो
आज चलो आज आपने पूछ लिया तो आपको नोट्स
मिल जाएंगे क्योंकि अगर आप आज पूछते नहीं
तो नोट्स नहीं मिलते। एक्टिवनेस देखना है
ना मेरे ग्रुप में। ग्रुप ऐसे थोड़ी ना
बनवाया मैंने आप लोगों से कि बस टाइम पास
करेंगे। नहीं भैया हम टाइम पास करने वाले
नहीं है।
और अगर आप लोगों को ग्रुप्स के नहीं मालूम
है तो आप लोग जो यहां पर नए हैं तो ग्रुप
ज्वाइन कर सकते हो क्योंकि डिस्क्रिप्शन
में एक ग्रुप हमने दिया हुआ है। बनाया हुआ
है लिंक उसका।
Telegram का जहां पर हम क्लास के नोट्स
शेयर कर सकते हैं। रिसोर्सेज शेयर करते
हैं। मैं वो भी मेरे द्वारा ही किए
जाएंगे।
उसके बाद मैं इसको भी थोड़ा टाइम लगेगा।
बिकॉज़ आपका टाइम बचाने की कोशिश कर रहा
हूं मैं।
बस हो गया।
हेडलाइन उसके बाद
गुड इतना ही है। नेक्स्ट हो गया। तो ये
हमने ऐड कर लिया। अब मुझे क्या करना है?
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की डिटेल्स को हमें क्या
करना है? फैच करना है। तो सबसे पहले हमें
क्या करना है? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम ओएस
डिटेल्स
डिटेल्स हमें क्या करनी है? रिकॉर्न करनी
है। डिटेल्स रिकॉर्न। तो चलो फिर कैसे कर
सकते हैं? इसके लिए भी हमने क्या किया हुआ
है? कोड लिखा हुआ है कहां पर? ये रहा। तो
ये रहा मैं इसको समझा दूंगा आपको। ये रहा
परफेक्ट।
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है कट कॉपी पेस्ट करने
में या लाइन बाय लाइन लिख के दिखाऊं तो
क्योंकि आपका टाइम बच जाएगा इससे। कोई
प्रॉब्लम है आप बताओ। देखो यहां पर हमने
क्या किया? इसी में सेम वेरिएबल है कॉल
आइटम।
ओके मैं इसको चेंज कर देता हूं।
कॉल आइटम कलेक्शन आइटम लो सेव कर दिया
wmआईसी सर्विस डॉट यहां पर देखो वहां पर
हमने उसको कॉल किया था यहां पर wmआईसी
सर्विस डॉट एग्जीक्यूट क्वरी और इसके अंदर
जो क्वरी मेंशन की जाती है ना जैसे आपको
पता है एसक्यूएल इंजेक्शन सबको पता है
एसक्यूएल
एसक्यूएल एसक्यूएल क्वरीज के बारे में
सबको पता है तो सेम है देखो सेलेक्ट ऑल
फ्रॉम विन 32 ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम जैसे मैंने
आपको क्लास बताई थी तो आप ऐसे इसको यूज़ कर
सकते हो बिल्कुल एसक्यूएल की तरह सेलेक्ट
ऑल उसके बाद इसके अंदर आपको अगर
इंफॉर्मेशन निकालनी है तो वो पांच इनेशन
ऐसी निकलेंगी वो पांच इनेशन कैसे निकलेगी
क्योंकि अभी मैंने यहां पर फॉर लूप क्यों
यूज़ किया है फॉर लूप इसलिए यूज़ किया है
ताकि जब ये रिटर्न जो ये हमने यूज़ की है
क्यूरी ये रिटर्न करती है बल्क में इनेशन
एक बार में ही तो मुझे क्या करना है उसके
अंदर अपने रिलेटेड इनेशन को फाइंड आउट
करना है। इसलिए मैं क्या कर रहा हूं? ईच
किसका फॉर लूप को यूज़ किया और फॉर लूप में
हमने इसका रेफरेंस सेव किया। रेफरेंस सेव
करके वन बाय वन इनेशन निकाली। देखो
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम का नाम डॉट कैप्शन डॉट
वर्जन डॉट ओएस आर्किटेक्चर डॉट रजिस्टर्ड
यूजर डॉट इंस्टॉल डेट। ठीक है? तो ये
पांचों इनेशन यहां से निकल जाएंगी। किसकी
हेल्प से? फॉर लूप की हेल्प से और एक-एक
करके वो लाइन सेव हो जाएगी। क्लियर है यह
चीज? [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] यह चीज
क्लियर है?
अगर आपकी यह चीज क्लियर है फिर हम चलते
हैं नेक्स्ट पर।
ओके अच्छी बात है। अगर आपको ये चीज क्लियर
है तो अभी हमने क्या किया? अभी हमें यह
पता चल गया कि टारगेट मशीन पर कौन सा
ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम चल रहा है? कौन सा बिल्ड
वर्जन है। तो नेक्स्ट रिकॉन का पार्ट क्या
है? हमारा नेक्स्ट रिकॉन का पार्ट हमारा
क्या है? बताओ। नेक्स्ट रिकॉन का पार्ट
हमारा क्या है? नेटवर्क।
किसी भी अभी दूसरी चीज भी आपको पता होनी
चाहिए। ठीक है? नेक्स्ट रिकॉर्ड का पार्ट
हमारा क्या है? कि जो
एक बार हमने मशीन कॉम्प्रोमाइज कर ली।
मशीन कॉम्प्रोमाइज करने के बाद जब हम
फर्स्ट टाइम एक्सेस लेते हैं तो हम क्या
करना चाहते हैं? हम लेटरल मूवमेंट करना
चाहते हैं। हम पीवेट करना चाहते हैं। तो
इन सबके लिए हमें क्या चाहिए? इन सबके लिए
हमें चाहिए नेटवर्क लेआउट। इन सबके लिए
हमें क्या चाहिए? उस पर्टिकुलर मशीन की
नेटवर्क लेआउट। तो, इसके लिए भी एक क्लास
होती है। वो क्लास कौन सी है? आपकी विन 32
नेटवर्क अप्टर कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। सेम विन 32
नेटवर्क अप्टर कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस। यहां जो
टेक्स्ट लिखा है, वो आप खुद से पढ़ लेना।
आपको शेयर कर दूंगा। मैं आपको मतलब समझाता
हूं। ये भी क्या है? एक बिल्ट इन क्लास है
जो क्या करती है? आपका जो कंप्यूटर है
उसका जो नेटवर्क अपर है जैसे कि इथरनेट हो
गया, वाईफाई हो गया, वाईफाई कार्ड हो गया
या वर्चुअल कार्ड्स हो गया। उनकी जो भी
टीसीपी आईपी सेटिंग्स है या जो भी नेटवर्क
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है उनको मैनेज और स्टोर करती
है। उनकी टीसीपी आईपी सेटिंग्स और जो
नेटवर्क कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस है आपके इस क्लास के
अंदर क्या होती है? स्टोर होती हैं। और एज
ए रेटिमर्स ये हम यहां से क्या-क्या इनेशन
निकाल सकते हैं? यहां से हम एक्टिव IPपी
एड्रेस की इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते हैं।
डिफॉल्ट गेटवे की इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते
हैं। और जो यह ग्रीन कलर में लिखा हो ना
यह वो पैरामीटर है जो आप यूज़ करोगे इस
क्लास के साथ ये इन पर्टिकुलर इनेशन
निकालने के लिए। डीएनएस सर्वर की
इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते हैं। मैक एड्रेस की
इनेशन निकाल सकते हो और डीएपी सर्वर की
डिटेल्स आप ये पांच इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते
हैं इस पर्टिकुलर क्लास की हेल्प से। ओके?
इस पर्टिकुलर कास्ट की हेल्प से आप ये
पांच इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल सकते हैं और इसके
सामने बिल्कुल इजी लैंग्वेज में लिखा है।
ये आप लोग खुद से पढ़ लोगे।
ये आप लोग खुद से पढ़ लो पढ़ लोगे।
अदरवाइज आपका क्या है कि बहुत टाइम लग
जाएगा। मैं आपको सीधा कोड दिखा देता हूं
जो हम इसके ऊपर एग्जीक्यूट करने वाले हैं।
ठीक है?
गुड। तो चलिए फिर हम चलते हैं फिर से।
इसका जो कोड है हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं यह
रहा। इसका कोड हम यूज़ करने वाले हैं। यह
रहा।
कंट्रोल सी करते हैं। फिर से चलते हैं
अपने इसके ऊपर। इस कोड को भी समझा देता
हूं मैं आपको। इस कोड में ऐसा क्या है? तो
इसमें सेकंड में हम क्या निकालेंगे? ये
रहा। तो चलो इसको हम क्या करते हैं? अरेंज
कर देते हैं।
तो देखो सेम है। wmआई सर्विस डॉट
एग्जीक्यूट कर। सेलेक्ट ऑल फ्रॉम विन 32
नेटवर्क अप्टर कॉन्फ़िगरेशन। फिर वेयर आईपी
इनेबल इक्वल टू ट्रू मतलब क्या है कि जब
यह क्यूरी एग्जीक्यूट की गई जब यह क्यूरी
एग्जीक्यूट होगी आपके विंडोज के अंदर ठीक
है जब ये डब्ल्यूएमआई क्यूरी एग्जीक्यूट
होगी तो सबसे पहले ये क्या करेगी नेटवर्क
अप्टर की लिस्ट निकालेगी उसके बाद हमने एक
कंडीशन मेंशन की है। इस कंडीशन का मतलब
क्या है कि हम चाहते हैं कि मुझे सिर्फ
उन्हीं नेटवर्क कार्ड्स की डिटेल मिले। या
मैं फिल्टर आउट करना चाहता हूं कि मुझे
सिर्फ जो आईपी आईपी इन एड्रेस की
इंफॉर्मेशन मिले या जो मुझे नेटवर्क की
डिटेल मिले मुझे एक्टिव नेटवर्क की डिटेल
मिले। मुझे पैसिव नेटवर्क की चाहिए ही
नहीं। मुझे वो इंफॉर्मेशन चाहिए ना
जहां-जहां पर आईपी कॉन्फ़िगर है। जहां-जहां
पर एक्टिव कनेक्शन है। पैसिव कनेक्शन मैं
करूंगा क्या? उसका नाम मिलेगा, ना उस पे
आईपी एड्रेस मिलेगा, ना कुछ मिलेगा। तो
मुझे क्या चाहिए? एक्टिव कनेक्शन की
इनेशन। तो एक्टिव कनेक्शन की इनेशन
निकालने के लिए हम एक कंडीशन मेंशन की
आईपी इनेबल्ड इक्वल टू ट्रू। इसीलिए सेम
हमने ऐड लाइन आपको पता है एक फंक्शन है।
इसके अंदर हर बार क्या हो रहा है? ये एक
उसका वेरिएबल इसका पैरामीटर है। फंक्शन के
अंदर हम क्या कर रहे हैं? पैरामीटर पास कर
रहे हैं। हर बार क्या हो रहा है कि वो एक
स्क्रिप्ट में ऐड हो रहा है। देन यहां पर
निकाल रहे हैं ऑब्जेक्ट आइटम डिस्क्रिप्शन
मैक एड्रेस आईपी एड्रेस डिफॉल्ट गेटवे
डीएससीपी सर्वर डीएनएस सर्वर सर्च ऑर्डर।
ठीक है? जो मैंने वहां पर मेंशन किया था
स्क्रिप्ट में। सेम वही पैरामीटर मैंने
यहां पर यूज़ किया। देखोगे आईपी एड्रेस,
डिफॉल्ट गेटवे, ग्रीन वाला, डीएनएस सर्वर,
सर्च ऑर्डर, मैक एड्रेस, डीएसीपी सर्वर।
सेम यहां पर मैंने अभी अब की बार क्या
कंडीशन में यूज़ किए हैं। देखो यहां देखोगे
इफ नॉट मतलब ये चेक कर रहा है कि कंडीशन
लगा ली और जो आपको उस पर्टिकुलर कलेक्शन
आइटम यहां पर भी एक वेरिएबल की प्रॉब्लम
हो सकती है। ये रहा कॉल आइटम है। यहां पर
मुझे इसको चेंज करना होगा। तो इसको मैं
क्या करता? ये आपके साथ मैं शेयर कर
दूंगा। चिंता मत कीजिए। ओके? आपको मिल
जाएगी। ये
हो गया कलेक्शन आइटम। तो इसके अंदर जो
वेरिएबल है इसके अंदर जो इंफॉर्मेशन स्टोर
हुई किसकी इस क्यूरी की उसमें से हम वन
बाय वन इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल रहे हैं। उसका
डिस्क्रिप्शन उसका मैक एड्रेस उसका आईपी
एड्रेस ठीक है और कंडीशन इसलिए लगाया कि
अगर उसमें कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशनेशन नहीं है
तो फिर मुझे कोई फायदा नहीं है इधर। जो
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन मिलेगी सिर्फ वही कंडीशन के
अंदर वाली एग्जीक्यूट होगी। अंडरस्टुड
एवरीवन?
ठीक है? मैं बता दूंगा अगर आज की क्लास
में नहीं एग्जीक्यूट करने के बाद और
प्रीवियस क्लास में बता दूंगा कि जब यह
पेलोड एग्जीक्यूट हुआ तो इसने डिफेंसिव
साइड जो आपका जो टारगेट मशीन है वहां पर
कौन-कौन से ट्रेसेस छोड़े कौन-कौन से
आर्टिफेक्ट छोड़े उस पे भी मैं आपको बता
दूंगा। ओके? इसकी चिंता मत करो। अभी आप जो
पढ़ने आए हैं वो पढ़ो। अभी हमने क्या कर
लिया? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम की भी इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल ली। ठीक है? अभी हमने ऑपरेटिंग
सिस्टम की इंफॉर्मेशन निकाल ली। रिकॉन की
अभी हम
इसकी भी इंफॉर्मेशन
हमने क्या किया? नेटवर्क डिटेल्स के भी
रिकॉर्ड कर लिया।
नेटवर्क
डिटेल्स रिकॉर्न भी कर लिया हमने। इसके भी
रिकॉर्न कर लिया हमने। अभी नेक्स्ट आता
क्या है? एज ए रेड टिमर अभी हमारे पास
क्या इनेशन है? ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम इनेशन।
उसके बाद दूसरी इंफॉर्मेशन हमारे पास क्या
है? नेटवर्क इंफॉर्मेशन। तीसरी चीज भी हम
क्या करते हैं? एक तीसरी इंफॉर्मेशन और
चाहिए होती है हमें। वो कौन सी इंफॉर्मेशन
है? तीसरी हम [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़]
चाहते हैं कि जो हमारी मशीन है उस पर लोकल
यूज़र्स की इंफॉर्मेशन भी हमें चाहिए।
कौन-कौन से लोकल यूज़र्स बने हुए हैं? लोकल
यूज़र्स की इंफॉर्मेशन हमें क्यों चाहिए?
कोई बताएगा?
हमें टारगेट मशीन के ऊपर लोकल यूज़र्स की
इंफॉर्मेशन क्यों चाहिए?
हमें टारगेट यूजर के सिस्टम के ऊपर लोकल
यूज़र्स की इंफॉर्मेशन क्यों चाहिए? देखो
मुझे टारगेट सिस्टम के ऊपर लोकल यूज़र्स की
इंफॉर्मेशनेशंस दो कारणों से चाहिए। पहला
कारण क्या है कि मैं यह फाइंड आउट करना
चाहता हूं क्या सिस्टम पर कोई ऐसा यूज़र्स
एक्टिवेट है सिस्टम पे कोई ऐसा यूजर
अवेलेबल है वो भी कौन सा एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
अकाउंट जिसका पासवर्ड गेस किया जा सकता है
या उसको अब्यूज किया जा सकता है तो पहला
तो रीज़न यह था कि लोकल यूजर की इनेशन
फाइंड आउट करने का क्या था पहला रीज़न कि
मैं यह पता करना चाहता हूं कि सिस्टम पर
क्या कोई वीक एडमिनिस्ट्रेटिव यूजर अकाउंट
है जिसका पासवर्ड गेस किया जा सकता है
जिसको अब्यूज किया जा सकता है। दूसरा कारण
क्या है? दूसरा कारण मेरा यह है कि कुछ
सिस्टम एडमिनिस्टर्स क्या करते हैं कि वो
टेस्टिंग के लिए हिडन लोकल अकाउंट्स बनाकर
छोड़ देते हैं। कुछ सिस्टम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर्स टेस्टिंग के लिए हिडन
लोकल अकाउंट्स बनाकर छोड़ देते हैं। थे
जिसकी जो सिक्योरिटी होती है वो बहुत वीक
होती है। मनमान हो सकता है कि वहां पर
पासवर्ड ही ना हो। ठीक है? तो ये चीज पता
लगाने के लिए भी हम क्या करते हैं? लोकल
यूज़र्स इंफॉर्मेशन
कलेक्ट करते हैं। लोकल यूजर इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करते हैं। ये इंफॉर्मेशन
निकालने के लिए भी। ये दोनों कारण पता चल
गया आपको दोनों कारण। तो ये इंफॉर्मेशन
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए भी हमारे पास एक
क्लास है। वो क्लास कौन सी है हमारी? विन
32 यूजर अकाउंट क्लास। विन 32 यूजर अकाउंट
क्लास। ठीक है? अभी इससे हम कौन-कौन सी
इनेशन निकाल सकते हैं? इससे इंफॉर्मेशन
निकाल सकते हैं लोकल वर्सेस डोमेन अकाउंट।
हम यहां से यह फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं कि
कौन सा अकाउंट लोकल मशीन पर बना है और कौन
सा अकाउंट एक्टिव डायरेक्टरी डोमेन अकाउंट
है। दूसरी चीज क्या निकाल सकते हैं?
अकाउंट का स्टेट। दूसरी चीज हम क्या निकाल
सकते हैं? अकाउंट स्टेट और एक्टिविटी।
डिसेबल्ड या लॉक्ड। दूसरा हम ये चीज
फिल्टर आउट कर सकते हैं कि कौन सा यूजर
अकाउंट एक्टिव है। कौन सा डिसेबल्ड है या
जिसको लॉक किया जा चुका है। ठीक है? हम
क्या करना चाहते हैं? बेसिकली हम वो
पुराने एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट ढूंढना
चाहते हैं जो सबसे क्रिटिकल्स है जो
डिसेबल या लॉक आउट हो चुके हैं। ठीक है?
वो इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट करना चाहते हैं।
तीसरी चीज आप क्या कर सकते हो? पासवर्ड
कॉन्फ़िगरेशंस फ्लो आप फाइंड आउट करना
चाहते हो कि हम क्या पता लगाना चाहते हैं?
क्या कोई ऐसा अकाउंट है कि जिसे किसी
पासवर्ड की रिक्वायरमेंट नहीं है या कोई
ऐसा सर्विस अकाउंट है या कोई ऐसा ओल्ड
एडमिन अकाउंट है जिसका पासवर्ड कभी
एक्सपायर ही नहीं होता। जिसका पासवर्ड कभी
एक्सपायर ही नहीं होता। ठीक है? चौथी चीज
हम क्या करने वाले हैं कि अभी एसआईडी आईडी
हम फाइंड आउट करने हैं। कौन सी सिक्योरिटी
आइडेंटिफायर फाइंड आउट करना चाहते हैं?
अभी कुछ स्मार्ट एडमिन क्या करते हैं ना
वो जो फॉर एग्जांपल क्या होता है कि जब भी
आप क्फिगर करते हो विंडोज ऑपरेटिंग सिस्टम
को तो बाय डिफॉल्ट एक एडमिन अकाउंट होता
है एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर नाम से जिसकी आईडी
स्टार्ट एंड होती है इससे डश 500 से तो
कुछ स्मार्ट एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर क्या करते हैं
कि बोला ठीक है कोई हैकर हमें हैक ना करे
हम क्या करते हैं एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट
का जो नाम था उसको चेंज कर देते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल उसका कुछ भी नाम रख दिया स्मार्ट
लोग है ना कि उन्होंने बोला ठीक है हम
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर का नाम बदल देंगे। लोग तो
सबसे पहले क्या करते हैं? स्क्रिप्ट टडी
का खासकर क्या करते हैं कि वो
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर अकाउंट को ही फाइंड आउट
करते हैं। अगर नहीं मिला तो बोला ठीक है
नहीं अवेलेबल होगा। तो ये चीज को उन्होंने
जुगाड़ कर लिया। बट प्रोफेशनल्स क्या करते
हैं? कोई बात नहीं आप नाम बदल सकते हो ना।
हमें यह तो पता है कि जो एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर
अकाउंट है उसकी एसआईडी कैसे होती है। कुछ
ऐसे स्टार्ट होती है। मतलब यह फ्रंट पार्ट
होता है लेकिन एंड इसी से होती है। तो
हमने क्या किया ड्यूरिंग इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
गैदरिंग एस आईडी को कलेक्ट किया और एसआईडी
को जो जितने यूजर की लिस्ट मेरे पास आई ना
उसके एसआईडी से कंपेयर कर लिया और जैसे
कंपेयर किया मुझे पता चल गया कि ओके आपने
तो एडमिन का नाम बदल दिया लेकिन
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तो है। ओके जिसका
एडमिनिस्ट्रेटर तो है तो हम एसआईडी को भी
वह क्या कर सकते हैं यहां से गैदर कर सकते
हैं। उसके बाद डिस्क्रिप्शन नोट्स ये क्या
होता है कि कुछ लोग क्या करते हैं ना कि
जो अकाउंट क्रिएट करते हैं उसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में कुछ नोट्स छोड़ देते
हैं। कई बार फॉर एग्जांपल कि ये एक बैकअप
सर्विस अकाउंट है और डश कई बार वहां पर
पासवर्ड भी स्टोर कर देते हैं। तो अगर कोई
ऐसा अकाउंट है यूजर अकाउंट जिसके
डिस्क्रिप्शन में या किसी नोट्स में कुछ
वैल्यूुएबल इंफॉर्मेशन है कोई क्लू है
जिससे आप इनिशियल एक्स अपने एक्सेस को
बढ़ा सकते हो या लेटरल मूवमेंट कर सकते हो
तो वो भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं यहां से
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं वो भी हम अपने
इसमें चेक आउट लिस्ट में ही करने वाले
हैं। तो चलो फिर इसका प्रैक्टिकल
डेमोंस्ट्रेशन डाल लेते हैं। कोई दिक्कत
नहीं है। इसके लिए भी कोड मेरे पास यह
रहा। मैंने पूरे मैक्सिमम जो यूज़ हो सकता
है उस पर्टिकुलर लाइब्रेरी का एज ए रेटिमर
वो मैंने कोड आपके सामने राइट डाउन किया
निकाला हुआ है। ठीक है? तो चलो फिर
नेक्स्ट चलते हैं भैया। नेक्स्ट में हमें
क्या करना है? थ्री। थ्री में हमें क्या
करना है?
यूजर
इंफॉर्मेशनेशन
रिक
हो गया। चलो फिर कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं। यहां
पे हमने पेस्ट कर दिया। कोई दिक्कत नहीं
है। तो, यह कोड आप पढ़ लोगे। मुझे उम्मीद
है आप लोगों से। यह हो गया आपका। नेक्स्ट
हो गया। यहां पर सेम सेलेक्ट ऑल फ्रॉम
ऑब्जेक्ट आईडी, नेम, एसआईडी, लोकल अकाउंट,
डिसेबल, लॉकआउ, पासवर्ड रिक्वायर्ड ये सब
ऐसे आप क्या कर सकते हो? खुद से पढ़ लोगे।
इजी है ना आप लोगों के लिए पढ़ना। इसमें
कुछ ऐसा नहीं होगा कि जो आप लोग ना पढ़
सको। मैं आपको प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा। क्योंकि
ओबीजी आइटम ये रहा। यहां पर भी
सही होना चाहिए।
ओबीj आइटम डॉट नेम आईजी आइटम डॉट नेम ये
रहा।
ओके ओके वेट वेट
कॉल आइटम ही है ना यहां पर।
क्योंकि मैं बाद में गलती नहीं करना चाहता
किसी भी प्रकार की वरना इसको डीबग करते रह
जाएंगे हम।
और फिर भी कोशिश करेंगे क्योंकि हमारी जो
गलतियां होंगी इनहीं में मिलेंग वेरिएबल्स
नेम्स में डोंट वरी
वी विल ट्राई कि हम गलतियां ना करें। तो
चलो नेक्स्ट अभी हम बात करते हैं। ये
यूज़र्स की इनेशन मिल गई। यहां तक क्लियर
है?
अभी तो काफी टाइम लग जाएगा यार। बाकी मुझे
लगता है कि कल करनी पड़ेगी नेक्स्ट क्लास
में। ठीक है? बाकी मुझे लगता है कि
नेक्स्ट क्लास में करना पड़ेगा।
इट विल टेक टाइम क्योंकि हमें मैक्सिमम पे
लोड बनाना पड़ेगा और शायद आप लोगों को
इसको और भी समझना है। सबको समझना है ना ये
कोड।
अदरवाइज बहुत देखो कितना बड़ा हो गया।
काफी बड़ा है ना कोड।
तो कंटिन्यू नेक्स्ट क्लास में करें।
कंटिन्यू नेक्स्ट क्लास में करें। फिर
मुझे पता है कि आप लोगों का फ्लो टूट
जाएगा। बट फ्लो का क्या करें भैया? जब
हमें थोड़ा सा और इस पर टाइम देना पड़ेगा।
अराउंड आधा घंटा देना पड़ेगा। काफी लेट हो
जाएंगे हम।
चलिए [नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] फिर हम
एक काम करेंगे। इसको नेक्स्ट क्लास में
कंटिन्यू करेंगे। धीरे-धीरे करेंगे। क्या
प्रॉब्लम है? ओके?
तो किसी कोई डाउट है रिलेटेड टू द क्लास
जो मुझसे पूछना चाहता है तो पूछ सकते हो
आप लोग
ओके नोट्स मिल जाएंगे
यस
नोट
व्हाट यू वांट टू से
ऐसा तो नहीं बोलने वाले ऐसा छोड़ो ना क्या
बकवास कर रहे हो बंद करो इनको
ऐसा तो कुछ दिल में सवाल नहीं है।
पेज का कोड नहीं बन जाएगा। हो गया। इसके
बाद आपको बताऊं क्या बच गया? आपका बच गया
मैं
ओनली पेलोड बच गया पावर सेल का।
कल किसने देखा है? ट्रेवल बाबू कल हमने
देखा है।
कुछ लोग बहुत स्लो है यहां पर।
नोबक्स
मुझे पता है आपका फ्लो बना है लेकिन देखो
उसके बाद मुझे एग्जीक्यूट भी करवाना फ्लो
कल भी बन जाएगा मैं कल कल भी ले लूंगा ये
क्लास कंटिन्यू कल है बैक टू बैक आपकी
क्लास कल भी है प्रॉमिस अभी अनाउंसमेंट
मिल जाएगी आपको थोड़ी देर में
आपका फ्लो नहीं टूटेगा रिवीजन कर लेना एक
बार जो मैंने आपको बताया था आपका फ्लो
नहीं टूटेगा अगर आप ग्रुप का पार्ट हो
आपको मैं ग्रुप का लिंक भेज देता हूं आप
लोगों को बता देता हूं अगर यहां पर हमारा
जो YouTube चैनल है YouTube चैनल के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में ही आपको मिल जाएगा हमारा
लिंक
YouTube चैनल के डिस्क्रिप्शन में ही मिल
जाएगा हमारा लिंक। ठीक है? यह रही क्लास।
इसको ओपन करो।
ये मैं इसको कोड देना पड़ेगा जिसप मुझे
वेट वेट कनेक्शन को भेजना है।
ये डिस्क्रिप्शन है। ये देखो कितना अच्छा
कमेंट। ओ कसार।
ये रहा। ओपन ये न्यू टैब। ये रहा।
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको मिल जाएगा। कैंसिल
कंट्रोल सी और मैं आपको भेज देता हूं।
ओके देखो यार इललीगल करने के लिए मैं किसी
को गाउ नहीं करूंगा। गाइड नहीं करने वाला।
डेली क्लास यार एक चीज बताऊं आप लोगों को
सच बोलूं मैं कि
हां tlegram में भेजूंगा मैं
[नाक से की जाने वाली आवाज़] तो सच ये
बोलूंगा मैं आपको कि आप लोग
जितने मुझे चाहिए उतने नहीं आते
हां इससे मैं आपको देखो कल की क्लास में
बता दूंगा ना क्यों इतना मुझे पता है
एक्साइटमेंट है आपका मैं बता दूंगा इसमें
क्या है कि कुछ इवेंट आईडी कम हो गई कुछ
इवेंट आईडी कम हो गई देखो कोड तो बढ़ गया
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोड तो स्मॉल भी हो
जाता कंप्रेसर कोड से फर्क नहीं पड़ता
इतना ज्यादा। अभी क्या मैं आपको सिखा रहा
हूं कितने तरीके हैं। मैं आपका इंटरेस्ट
देख के मैं क्लासेस को एक्सटेंड करता रहा
हूं। एक फॉर योर काइंड इनेशन एक चीज बताता
हूं आप लोगों को मैं कि
ये इस क्लास का पार्ट भी नहीं था। जो ये
क्लासेस पढ़ा रहा हूं ना मैं प्रैक्टिकल 4
5 6 ये इस क्लास का पार्ट ही नहीं था।
ये इस क्लास का पार्ट ही नहीं था।
मैंने आउट ऑफ सिलेबस पढ़ाया है। यह मुझे सब
फंडामेंटल पढ़ाकर उसके बाद जस्ट आपको
एमएसएफ वेनम के पेलोड इस पे एग्जीक्यूट
करवा के दिखाने थे। वो जो मैं दिखाऊंगा
अपकमिंग क्लास में। बट ये मैं ऑन इंटरेस्ट
में आप लोगों के लिए वो कर गया कि मैंने
पढ़ा देता हूं यार बच्चों को कुछ सीखने को
मिलेगा जो चीज अवेलेबल नहीं है। सिर्फ ऐसे
लेकिन आप लोग मेरे को वो नहीं करते यार।
सपोर्ट नहीं करते। आप मेरे को सपोर्ट तो
करो एक बार।
आप एक बार मेरे को सपोर्ट तो करो। मैं
आपको एथिकल हैकिंग में ऐसीसी चीजें
सिखाऊंगा।
YouTube पर तो नहीं मिलेंग आपको। ठीक है?
YouTube पर नहीं। YouTube पर नहीं मिलने
वाली आप लोगों को।
बट आप लोग मेरे को सपोर्ट करो एक बार। हम
बेस्ट देंगे। ठीक है?
डेफडमी बेस्ट बनाएगी। आपके लिए बेस्ट
कंटेंट प्रोवाइड करेगी और कोई तो मैं अपनी
गारंटी लेता हूं मैं आपको बेस्ट प्रोवाइड
करूंगा। अगर मुझे आप लोगों को बेस्ट देने
के लिए कहीं पर पेड कंटेंट भी अगर मुझे
यहां पर डिलीवर करना पड़ जाए। आई विल
ट्राई टू माय बेस्ट। बट इतनी आसानी नहीं
है यार।
ठीक है। मैं यहां पैसे के लिए काम नहीं कर
रहा। ठीक है। ना मैं कोई सैलरी लेता।
कभी नितेश सर से आप पूछोगे तो सचिन सर
सैलरी नहीं लेते। ठीक है?
बस आप लोगों के लिए पढ़ाता हूं मैं। अपना
पीसीएस टाइम निकालता हूं। आप लोग यह समझ
सकते हो कि मैं आप लोगों को सिखाना चाहता
हूं या यह समझ सकते हो कि मेरा यह लालच है
कि मैं आप अपना चैनल ग्रो करवा रहा हूं।
वो आपकी मर्जी है। कुछ भी समझ सकते हो।
लेकिन मैंने आपसे एक भी पैसा नहीं लिया।
डेली बेसिस पर क्लास तो नहीं ले सकता
क्योंकि मेरी अपनी मजबूरी है। लेकिन
मैक्सिमम मैं ट्राई कर करने की कोशिश करता
हूं आजकल कि आपकी क्लासेस मैक्सिमम टू
मैक्सिमम हो जाए। मैक्सिमम टू मैक्सिमम
आपको ज्यादा से ज्यादा पढ़ा सकूं। मैं
ज्यादा से ज्यादा क्लास ले सकूं। बट क्या
है कि कई बार आप लोग इतना नर्वस करते हो
कि जैसे मेरे प्रीवियस क्लासेस को उठा के
देख लो। आप आते ही नहीं। आप देखोगे नहीं।
अगर मैं अपने YouTube स्टूडियो को उठाकर
अगर मैं यह चेक करूं कि आपकी क्लिक रेट
क्या है? आप लोग कितना आगे उस स्विच को
पढ़ते हो? मुझे पता है वन पता है एक
वीडियो लोग कितनी ज्यादा देर नहीं देखते।
पांच से सात मिनट से ज्यादा नहीं देखते।
ठीक है? वह चीज
तो यार आप लोगों की मर्जी है।